it has led to the death of 70
000 Americans because of fentanyl that's
300 people a day when they're coming
across yes we're going to use lethal
Force China is sending these chemicals
Here We Go Again politicians blaming
everyone except themselves for the
increase in drug overdoses because the
real culprit all along has been failed
government policy prohibition creates
black markets as a result people don't
know what they're buying and drugs are
often more dangerous or even fatal so
why did traffickers start putting
fentanyl in the drug Supply well it's
economics Sentinel is cheaper to produce
and more potent than heroin allowing for
smaller volumes to be smuggled and what
led to the uptick in heroin use
government of course when politicians
crack down on legal opioid prescriptions
the use of illegal opioids predictably
spiked now we're seeing this play out
with xylazine an animal tranquilizer cut
with fentanyl prohibitionists see this
as the next big thing in the drug war
sadly this election cycle you won't hear
major party politicians talk about the
only workable solution to this problem
in the drug crisis by ending the drug
war